please guys I want to go have lunch at
mar-a-lago a lady
cameraman very strange what do you do
during your period can you film yeah I'm
an excellent multitasker Lexus I think
it's like that
I used to peer in on her all the time
when she would wear very loose nighties
that's how I knew when my mother was
going to bed and doing it so we cleaned
up the body and we continued the
bachelor party I like but stuff we step
right out of a bradley's catalogue and
now he's the Schlage guy and I said I'll
chop your legs off whoever said that and
she didn't believe me and that's why she
was so funny and a lot of touch there
I'm tired I want a hamburger I farted a
little bit on that one
everybody's got it get out